there is something magical and mystical  about what happens when you just string  a few sort of actions together that are  self-esteem building or moving you  towards a certain goal even if they're  super tiny right like you create this  momentum and that momentum build  suddenly you're more enthusiastic about  taking that next step than you were one  step prior because you did these two it  could be tiny it could be like I brush  my teeth you know in the whatever it is  that you're struggling with and then you  do that it's like this idea of  self-esteem is a function of doing  esteemable acts and those esteemable  acts can be on on behalf of yourself  right and when they're small but those  things they really build in this  compounding kind of way that can really  redirect your life so it is really  important to start small